Chris Evans thank you Mr Speaker a
constituent of mine who is a mother and
a carer for her disabled son wrote to me
recently she told me she's watching
every penny and she's deeply worried
about how she will afford energy in the
coming winter
she is one of the nine in ten families
with a disabled child the family fun
says a struggling to afford simple
household bills what direct advice does
he have for my constituent and thousands
like her who are in a hopeless situation
yeah yeah
well Mr Speaker there are indeed many
people suffering at the moment and uh
and I you know I feel very sorry for the
honorable gentleman's constituent the
government have supported households
with the rising cost of living by
maintaining the energy price guaranteed
two and a half thousand pounds from
April to June 23 23 saving households an
addition of 160 pounds over the course
of the winter the government were paying
on average about half of uh People's
Energy bills and for those living in
households where there is a disability
of course there's been an extra payment
of 150 pounds thank you Mr Speaker most
recent statistics published by the Welsh
government showed that almost a quarter
of those living in the private rented
sector in Wales are living in fuel
poverty this is compared to only 13
percent of those people who own their
own homes can the Secretary of State set
out what additional support those who
live in the private center sector will
get from the government because the
reality is their rents are going up
their fuel bills are going up and the
government now just seems to be sitting
idle and doing nothing to support these
people
well Mr Speaker the government is
certainly not sitting highly around not
supporting people
um the government the government don't
differentiate between whether somebody
is in private accommodation or is
renting accommodation but what the
government have done is to stipulate
those who are the least well off will
get the most support and that is why we
ensure that pensions have gone up in
line with inflation the minimum wage has
gone up in line with inflation and those
living on benefits have seen their
benefits rise in line with inflation
Cinemas Joe Jones
thank you Mr Speaker as fewer poverty
runs rampant across Wales doesn't the
sector of State realize how appalling it
looks at a time when families right
across Wales are struggling shell are
making 61 000 pounds a minute when will
his government get a grip close the
loopholes with billions and extend the
windfall attacks
little gentlemen should be aware the
government have extended the windfall
tax and the government have are charging
very high levels of tax indeed around
three times the usual level of tax on
companies that are taking oil out of the
North Sea and that's why it's so
extraordinary that those who on the one
hand call for a windfall tax on energy
companies don't recognize that we're
already living it and don't want to
support the government in allowing more
oil and gas we exploited from the North
Sea which will enable us to raise even
more in taxation Joel Jones
go on thank you Mr Speaker Tory Minister
seem to think that the energy crisis is
all over I'm not sure when the last time
the Secretary of State struggled to pay
an energy bill but bills are still
almost double what they were before The
Crisis began and the Tory government has
scrapped the vital support so does the
Secretary of State agree with me that
the way to get energy prices energy
builds down for good is to back Labor's
policy to retrofit 19 million homes and
to reach a thousand a hundred percent
clean Power by 2030.
Speaker I I've no idea who'd be paying
for the proposal of The Honorable
gentleman is putting forward no doubt
it'd be one of those things uh that one
of the many things that is going to be
paid for uh using the same tax about
half a dozen times what I can say the
honorable gentleman is that he'll be
very pleased no doubt today that
inflation is down yet again and the
government are well on course for
achieving their target of cutting
inflation by half as well as growing the
economy so
nonetheless food inflation remains up
but the poorest hardest with trustful
trust warning that the past year saw a
record 185
000 food Parcels provided in Wales
meanwhile supermarkets continue to make
record-breaking profits many speak of a
greed flation crisis European
governments have negotiated with
supermarkets to cap food prices why
won't his government do this too yeah
for Mr Mr Speaker I've already mentioned
some of the help and support the
government have given to the lease well
off I want to just remind The Honorable
lady that in addition to what to to the
pensions and benefits Rising line with
inflation there are payments of 900
pounds to those on benefits 300 pounds
to pensioners 150 to those in households
with disability and quite frankly Mr
Speaker The Honorable lady is seriously
worried about food inflation she should
be talking to her colleagues in the
Welsh uh labor government who are
propping up the Welsh labor government
about their ridiculous proposals to to
ban meal deals which will make meals
even more expensive for people in Wales
protecting Wales because Tori brexit has
served Wales
the EU withdrawal action the internal
architect have grabbed senad's Powers
paltry post-brexit funding is robbing
whales of millions enough is enough the
House of Lords recently passed Lord
Wiggler's Devol Powers Bill to prevent
any change to the Senate's powers
without a two-thirds vote majority from
MSS will the Secretary of State support
play camera's Bill and ensure that there
is time for debate or is he happy to see
the people of Wales lose the powers for
which they have voted time and again
hi Mr Speaker far from taking Powers
away from the Welsh government the
conservative government have on a number
of occasions actually increased power to
the Welsh government by leaving the
European Union we have repatriated
powers from Brussels where we've been
governed by an unelectable elite and
brought them back to both Westminster
and to Cardiff Now The Honorable lady
wants to uh wants to stop money being
wasted she should have a word with her
colleagues implied country who are
propping up this Welsh labor government
as they lose hundreds of millions of
pounds hundreds of millions of pounds
wasted in the Betsy cadwalada Health
Service hundreds of millions of pounds
spent on an airport with no planes and
over 100 million pounds spent on
building on plans for a relief Road
that's never going to get built Let's
Twist question two Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker I have regular discussions
with cabinet colleagues on a range of
issues interest rates arising across the
world as countries manage Rising prices
due to the pandemic and Putin's illegal
invasion of Ukraine but I'm very pleased
to see that the UK average two and five
year fixed mortgage rates have declined
in recent months
it's worse
thank you Mr Speaker
we fall tax at the budget in March does
the minister agree that there are still
a few Tools in that Levy that mean
billions of pounds that could be used to
help Welsh households with the cost of
living and they've been ignored
well Mr Speaker the chancellor this
conservative government have bought in
Windfall taxes on energy companies on
oil which and gas which is coming out of
the North Sea energy companies are
paying around three times more than
other companies in taxation and I hope
the honorable lady will be supportive of
those companies that want to take more
oil and gas out of the out of the North
Sea so that we can raise even more in
taxation to support the lease well off
in the United Kingdom Secretary of State
Josh Stevens thank you Mr Speaker since
his government's mini budget 43 000
Welsh households have paid an extra 20.3
million pounds in mortgage payments so
that's a 20 million pound Tory mortgage
premium in just seven months his
government's economic recklessness
continues to cause misery for people
across Wales so will you take the
opportunity to apologize to them
Mr Speaker the the economic policies
being pursued by this government are
bringing inflation down as the news
today demonstrates and I very much hope
that the honorable lady will want to
celebrate the fact that inflation is now
falling and this United Kingdom
government committed a committing to
seeing inflation halved the policies of
The Honorable ladies party would push
inflation through the roots and push us
into another Financial catastrophe and
crisis of the sort that we saw the last
time they left office yes number three
Mr Speaker
Thursday with your permission Mr Speaker
I will answer questions three and four
together the government have established
Great British nuclear to drive forward
the UK's new nuclear program gbn will be
working with the government on access to
potential sites for new nuclear projects
and I will continue to build on the
clear cross Party Support there is to
promote Wales as the destination of
choice for one of the first projects
subtly almost subliminally making the
case for new nuclear in her constituency
but of course with the Advent of SMR
there's the opportunity for the
community to cross Wales to benefit from
nuclear clean energy so can I ask him
what questions he's had with ministerial
colleagues in desnes and with the Welsh
government to make sure that Wales is
primed to take advantage of this well Mr
Speaker I have had a meeting with the
the minister for for nuclear in desnes
but I also met yesterday with the
interim chair of gbn Simon Bowen and we
had a very interesting and informative
discussion around this emerging uh
technology which I think is very
exciting and offers huge potential for
Wales
thank you Mr Speaker I thank my right
I'm a friend for his answers thus far
clearly Wells has a bright future as
part of the new nuclear capability
across the United Kingdom what further
measures is he going to make for example
on Fusion as well as nuclear energy
that's already been provided
well Mr Speaker the government have set
out support for um uh for investigating
nuclear fusion but I fear that there
might be others better qualified to give
the detail on that but what I can say to
The Honorable gentleman is that in all
of the meetings I have had with various
stakeholders I have made the case for
Wales to be in the Forefront of
everyone's Minds as a place where we
could have a new reactor or SML our
technology and of course I've been
encouraged very much by the member for
unismond who's been an absolute Champion
for nuclear technology and not for
nothing is known across Wales as the
Atomic Kitten
but Mr Speaker is party talk of on
nuclear they talk the talk but you know
it was the Tories that previously pulled
the plug on new nuclear and wheels he
forgets yeah they've ballasted about GB
nuclear but two years on nothing has
happened Mr Speaker nothing at all isn't
this just more the same broken promises
from a territory government that has run
out of steam
well Mr Speaker
um it would be tempting but time would
prevent me from drawing attention to the
uh the very poor record of the last
Labor government when it came to nuclear
energy the fact of the matter is Mr
Speaker we are driving forward with a
new nuclear reactor at Hinckley we're
looking to bring forward a a an FID on a
nuclear reactor in the next term and Mr
Speaker the establishment of Great
British nuclear fully demonstrates our
commitment to nuclear technology
thank you Mr Speaker I wonder if the
minister in his conversations about
nuclear has discussed the pie in the sky
nature of small nuclear reactors if he's
discussed the lack of a cogent plan for
nuclear waste if he's discussed the
unenviable unit cost with the wheelchair
comparison to Renewables and has he
indicated to them that he's got a better
plan that's not your player yeah
um Mr Speaker the fact of the matter is
that when one considers all of the costs
of renewable energy a nuclear comes out
uh very well not least because it is
perfectly it is not possible to predict
energy where it is not possible Mr
Speaker it is not possible to predict
when exactly the sun's going to shine
all the wind's going to blow and that is
why nuclear has a role to play in our
March towards Net Zero by 2050.
Sloane Sykes me question five please Mr
Speaker
okay thank you Mr Speaker the tourism
industry in South Wales and Southwest
England is incredibly important and I
understand that councils on both sides
of the Bristol channel are in discussion
on how to progress this issue I'd be
happy to meet my honorable friend to
discuss it in more detail
and I thank my honorable friend for his
answer and I wonder ahead of that
meeting might he be able to secure an
analysis of a passenger ferry service
and the benefits to those businesses
between ilfracombe and South Wales
thank my honorable friend for that
question it's important that we grasp
all opportunities to level up our
economy through tourism and that could
include a passenger Ferry between
ilfracun and South Wales
of course many of the policy leavers
affecting the visitor economy in Wales
are devolved
and it's important that interested
parties work closely with the relevant
councils on the matter
Mr Speaker the UK government is
passionate about tourism unlike the
Welsh government who seem more focused
on putting in place tourism tax Stephen
Kennett question six please sir
Vanessa thank you Mr Speaker Steele is
vital to the UK and we are actively
engaging with our industry to secure a
positive and sustainable future
industrial sectors including steel have
been able to bid into government funds
worth more than one billion pounds to
support them to cut emissions and become
more energy efficient to even kill it
speaker the governments of the United
States and the EU have developed active
industrial strategies with multi-billion
pound Investments to support their Steel
Industries as they transition to Green
steel production and here in the UK the
Cavalry is coming in the form of a labor
government and our three billion pounds
what a contrast with the party opposite
which is completely enough utterly
asleep at the wheel on steel so when
will the Secretary of State start
standing up for our proud well steel
industry and when will he start getting
his colleagues in cabinet to wake up to
the fact that we are losing the race for
green steel investment
yeah
thank you Mr Speaker well The Honorable
member will be aware that the Secretary
of State for business in trade visited
Tata Steel in Portal but only very
recently and I think that shows her
commitment to it he'll also be aware of
the British industry supercharger that
was announced only a few months ago
which aims to bring energy costs for
energy intensive Industries such as
steel production in line with those of
other similar countries
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker healthcare
services are of course devolved to the
Welsh labor government but it is deeply
worrying that only last week the Welsh
government revealed that their target
for people waiting over two years for
treatment has once again been missed
with over 31 000 people waiting in pain
for over two years for their treatment
and in England with virtually 20 times
the population the equivalent figure is
virtually zero
one of the most important things to
improving Health Care Systems is the
ability to compare data there's a
problem though if different uh
legislators use different metrics so
will the UK government agree to an
agreement between the default Nations to
share the same data so that comparisons
can be made adequately
well Mr Speaker I think the honorable
gentleman makes a very good point indeed
we do need comparable data so that we
can see exactly what is going wrong in
the Health Service in Wales we already
know from the data we've got about the
31 000 people who've been waiting more
than two years in pain for treatment we
know that the Welsh government have a
copy of report the eui reported to
what's gone wrong in Betsy cadwalada
trust a report which they are sitting on
and trying to hold secret because it
points out that over 100 million pounds
was misspent whilst uh by the Health
Board under the control of a Welsh labor
government
right Mr
speaker Tuesday
Mr Speaker I have regular discussions
with cabinet colleagues on a range of
Transport matters hs2 will benefit
people traveling from North Wales to
London with the interchange at crew
providing shorter Journey times for
North Wales and is currently possible on
the west coast Mainline
Chester station is the key that can
unlock connectivity between England and
North Wales not only is connectivity
vital for thousands of rail users but
also for businesses on both sides of the
border and Beyond will government commit
to the rapid electrification of the
North Wales train line which will
transform the North Wales and Cheshire
Regional economy
well Mr Speaker I think
that's one of the best questions I've
heard from anyone on the opposite
benches so far this morning yes I think
that uh electrification of the North
Wales Coastline would be a very good
idea or certain improvements would be as
The Honorable lady will be aware and
there are various uh improvements to the
Welsh Railway structure being discussed
at the moment in our nap and I look
forward to our net being published
shortly Alexander Stafford
sir
Mr Speaker I have regular discussions
with cabinet colleagues to discuss
transport links between Wales and the
rest of the United Kingdom roads are
devolved to the Welsh labor government
and their opposition to the M4 relief
Road and indeed to any kind of road
building at all continues to hold the
Welsh economy back a matter which is of
great disappointment to myself and my
cabinet colleagues Alexander Stafford
thank you very much indeed Mr Speaker
the economy of Wales has always worked
on an East-West basis so for example if
you're starting a journey from Bangor in
the north it takes three times longer to
travel to college in the South than it
has a Manchester or to my seat of Rother
Valley can the sectors state of an
explanation then of why the Welsh
government has banned all new road
development or how that might possibly
help the Welsh economy here here
well Mr Speaker my right on my honorable
friend raises an excellent point and the
Welsh government's response to the
Rhodes review is absolutely
extraordinary their opposition to Road
building is going to hold the Welsh
economy back and I would urge the Welsh
labor government to reconsider the
impact of banning or road building on
the long-term prosperity of Wales the
Morgan
his budget in 2020 the Prime Minister
who was then the chancellor promised a
bypass
plan to my constituences on the road
they're with links oswestry in welshpool
can the Secretary of State tell me
whether that road will ever come to
fruition or whether that's just another
broken promise
um Mr Speaker I didn't hear all of that
question I think it related to the
fundamental bypass in uh in Midwest the
fact of the matter is Mr Speaker that
the the Welsh labor government will
continue to receive Barnet
consequentials for the road building
that takes place in England and it is a
matter for the Welsh labor government to
decide whether or not they wish to spend
that money on Building New Roads which
is something I would like to see them do
or whether they wish to keep throwing it
away on white elephants like the airport
which is losing help which is lost
hundreds of millions of pounds over the
last few years Dave Morgan question
number 10 Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker with permission I
will answer questions 10 and 11 together
this government is committed to
supporting the decarbonization of Welsh
industry we have committed 20 billion
pounds over the next two decades to the
deployment of innovative carbon capture
technology and this Builds on the
existing support for the high net
cluster in North Wales and Northwest
England and the 21 and a half million
pounds to develop the South Wales
industrial cluster Steve Morgan thank
you Mr Speaker the best way to bring
down bills in the long term for
businesses in Wales and across the UK is
to help transition Industries away from
fossil fuels that is why labor is
calling for a national wealth fund so
that we can help industries like still
win the race for the future can the
minister tell the house specifically
what steps he's taking to help heavy
industry decarbonize
well I thank him for that question of
course he's already aware of an array of
funds that are in place to help
decarbonization the carbon capture
utilization and storage infrastructure
fund the industrial fuel switching fund
the Industrial decarbonization Research
and Innovation Center the competitive
industrial energy transformation fund
and the industrial strategy challenge
fund amongst others molesterson
but the UK is the only country in the G7
whose steel industry is currently in
Decline yeah so why won't the government
end their sticking class to approach
match Labor's commitments to a three
billion pounds green steel fund and
invest in a long-term plan to
decarbonize the vital steel sector in
Wales
well I repeat what I said earlier which
is that the Secretary of State uh
has visited the plant in Portal but very
recently she's committed to it we do
need to see an electric art furnace that
is the way forward to protect jobs and
to ensure that we have steel production
in the UK
Stephen Crabb thank you Mr Speaker the
industrial Corridor that runs along
South Wales all the way west to my to my
kitchen is one of the most important in
the U
in the youth challenging when it comes
to decarbonization does my honorable
friend agree with me that the
government's policies the powering up
Britain a set of energy interventions
the Celtic Freeport that we secured
point the way to a successful
decarbonization strategy for this
critically important part of Wales yeah
well my writer of a friend of course is
is absolutely right there South Wales
doesn't have former oil and gas fields
in which we can store carbon but it does
have the Celtic Freeport and
non-pipeline transport of carbon
captured carbon to Fields elsewhere is
what will secure decarbonization for
South Wales
number 12 Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker the coronation saw people in
Wales and right across the United
Kingdom Come Together to celebrate the
monarchy it was a wonderful occasion and
it United our public and demonstrated
just how strong our Union is
there'll be more you Mr Speaker over the
coronation weekend I had the pleasure of
attending a fantastic coronation church
service in Howarth at Paris Church
listening to our brilliant Yorkshire
harpist Fiona Katie witup as well as
joining many of her community events and
I know that my right honorable friend
attended the similar sorts of events in
Wales which undoubtedly brought the
whole of the United Kingdom together so
what does my right honorable friend see
is the legacy of the coronation and the
Fantastic weekend of Community Spirits
Mr Speaker I thought it was notable that
his Royal Highness talked about the
importance of service and volunteering
being at the heart of the coronation and
encourages us all to take part in some
voluntary work so I was very pleased to
join the residents of panic Village in
my constituency for an afternoon of
litter picking the day after the
coronation which I thought was almost as
great an honor as attending the
coronation itself was it Jim Shannon
thank you Mr Speaker they thank the
minister very much for that there the
celebrations for the coronation and
Wales were exceptional the summer
blessings for the coronation of Northern
Ireland were equally successful does the
minister agree when it comes to
cementing the union the fact that all
four regions can be one country that's
Scotland Wales Northern and England
together is an indication of why the
Royal day is so important they always
create United Kingdom of Great Britain
and Northern Ireland is always better
together
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker to that wonderful
question I can only reply yes
demolition of crown Estates in Scotland
questions
thank you Mr Speaker this government is
committed to supporting renewable energy
generation in Wales including for the
Innovative tidal stream technologies
that motor ice and through our Flagship
contract for different scheme and
supporting the huge potential of our
floating offshore wind industry through
the 160 million pounds inflow Miss
funding for Port infrastructure
yeah yeah
it's a collection of counter States in
Scotland's allowed the Scottish
government of America here in supply
chain development for renewable energy
now 75 of the Welsh public want to see
counter States and Wales devolved so
that Wales can benefit from natural
resources and renewable energy while
Westminster listen to people of Wales
and so in our case Westminster Knows
Best
speak it evolving the crown Estates
would actually be very risky for Wales
given the fact that at the moment the
revenue spent by the UK treasury is
invested across the whole of the United
Kingdom but I can assure The Honorable
gentleman that this UK government will
be absolutely committed to seeing
renewable energy spread across the
United Kingdom alongside our other
priorities of Harvey halving inflation
cutting debt ending small votes and
reducing NHS waiting this in the areas
where we're responsible for doing so
Mr Speaker Anglesey leads the way in
renewable energy and yet it's being let
down by poor connectivity this week the
Britannia Bridge closed suddenly and
given there's a seven and a half ton
limit on the menai suspension bridge
it's created absolute chaos does the
second straight agree with me that labor
in Cardiff should be focused on building
a third Crossing
Mr Speaker The Honorable lady
representing Anglesey is absolutely
right about this the Welsh labor
government need to start building roads
and start building bridges as well
we now come to prime minister's
questions Sean Hudson
[Applause]
Mr Speaker this morning I had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duty